let F G and H be real valued functions
defined on the interval 0 to 1 and it
includes the boundary 0 & 1 that's what
the brackets tell us it wouldn't include
the boundaries if we had parentheses and
then they define the functions f of X is
equal to e to the x squared plus e to
the negative x squared G of X looks very
similar to f of X except we have this X
out here in front of the first term and
then we have H of X which looks very
similar to G of X and f of X except it's
got an x squared term right over there
and then they tell us if a B and C
denote respectively the absolute maximum
of F G and H on the interval then so a
is the maximum of F B is the maximum of
8 of G and then C is the maximum of H
and then they have a bunch of choices
that compare the maximum values now the
first thing that may or may not jump at
you're just looking at these equations
over here now we're over the interval 0
to 1 and let's just look at the the the
functions themselves let's just look at
the functions themselves the difference
is this one you can view has a 1
coefficient out front this has an X and
this has an x squared so over that
interval how are these functions going
to relate over that interval we know we
know that over the interval from 0 to 1
over the interval from 0 to 1 we know
that x squared is going to be less than
less than or equal to X which is going
to be less than or equal to 1 they all
equal each other at the right interval
at actually being equal to 1 so this is
going to be less than this which is
going to be less than that and these are
all positive values and the rest of the
the rest of the functions are the same
this is the same as that that's the same
as that and that is the same as that so
over the interval over the interval we
know we know that H of X is going to be
less than or equal to G of X which is
going to be less than or equal to f of X
which is going to be less than or equal
to f of X that just comes straight out
of this coefficient is going to be less
equal to this coefficient which is going
to be less than or equal to one over the
interval now with that said let's
actually try to figure out the maximum
value so I'll start with F I will start
with F so f of X let me just try it at
the boundaries F of 0 F of 0 is equal to
e to the 0 plus e to then e to the 0
squared plus e to the negative 0 squared
that's just e to the 0 plus e to the 0
which is 1 plus 1 which is 2 and then F
of 1 F of 1 is e to the 1 plus e to the
negative 1 this is e to the 1 or just e
I should say plus e to the negative 1
now this is clearly larger than that E
is 2.7 1 keeps going either negative 1
that's still going to be a positive
number obviously so this between the two
endpoints this seems to be a candidate
for the maximum point we don't know
that's the maximum point because the
function might have done something funky
in between so let me draw axes I can
draw a straighter line than that so we
know at 0 we took on the value 2 and at
1 at 1 we took on the value we took on
the value T plus 1 over E e plus 1 over
e or e to the negative 1 so that's that
value right over there
now we don't know what the function did
in between this would be the maximum
point this is the maximum point if if
the function did something like this if
it's constantly increasing the entire
time this would be the maximum point it
would not be the maximum point if the
function if the function looks something
like that and the way we can tell what
the function is doing is we can take the
derivative of f which tells us the slope
at any point over this interval and if
the derivative is constantly positive
that means we always have an upward
slope if the derivative is not always
positive then we have something like
this and then we can look for and then
we could actually look for that actual
maximum point so let's calculate the
derivative so f prime f prime of x is
equal to is equal to the derivative of e
to the x squared is 2
X e to the X square just using the chain
rule derivative of e to the negative x
squared is negative 2x e to the negative
x squared and let's see we could factor
out let's see we could factor out this
is equal to 2 e to X 2x e to the
negative x squared times so if you
factor if you divide this by e to the
negative x squared that's like at that's
like multiplying it times e to the x
squared so this becomes e to the 2x
squared minus 1 minus 1 now our question
is what is this is the slope over the
interval what is this doing at any point
well this value right here this right
here is always going to be greater than
or equal to 0 it'll be 0 at the
left-hand interval this remember this is
the slope the slope is 0 at the
left-hand interval which tells us it's
either a maximum or a minimum point but
then it's going to be positive after
that because this is going to be a
positive value and that this is going to
be a positive value remember negative
exponent does not mean a negative number
it means a fractional value it's going
to be 1 over e to the x squared so this
is always going to be greater than or
equal to 0 and so we need to figure out
is this always greater than or equal to
0 so we want to figure out is e the 2 x
squared minus 1 greater than or equal to
0 over the interval which is the same
thing as asking is e to the 2x squared
greater than or equal to 1 over the
interval I just added 1 to both sides of
this inequality and that's the same
thing as asking if you take the natural
log of both sides the natural log of
this is 2x squared the natural log of 1
is 0 so it's 2x squared greater than or
equal to 0 over the interval well yeah
sure it's going to be equal to 0 at X is
equal to 0 but then after every other
value as it approaches 1 it'll be
positive so this is true this is true so
this this thing is always going to be
greater than 0 over the interval which
tells us that the two parts of the
derivative are always going to be
greater than or equal to 0 so the
derivative itself the slope of the
function is
always greater than zero so always
greater than zero over the interval I
should say always greater than or equals
zero over over the interval from zero
from zero to one which tells us that the
slope is never negative
which tells us that actually no we know
that the slope is zero at zero so that
tells us that the graph looks something
like this the graph looks something like
this which tells us that the right
endpoint that f of one at when x equals
one f of 1 is the maximum point so this
indeed is this indeed is equal this
indeed is equal to a so we can actually
write this here f of X is less than or
equal is less than or equal to a now
let's think about H of a H of X and G of
X so f of 1 was its maximum point but G
of 1 if you take if you take G of 1 or H
of 1 it'll evaluate to F of 1 because if
you put a 1 here let's let's do that let
me just do it to make it clear so G of
so we already evaluated F of 1 right
over there G of 1 G of 1 is equal to we
hadn't let me make sure we can see the
so G of 1 is equal to 1 1 times e to the
1 plus e to the negative 1 that's G of 1
which is the same thing as F of 1 so
this is also equal to a and H of 1 H of
1 is the same thing it's 1 times it's 1
squared which is 1 times e to the 1 plus
e to the negative 1 which is also equal
to a so what do we have a situation
you're we we know we know that H of X
over the interval is less than or equal
to G of X is less than or equal to f of
X which is less than or equal to a and
actually the only point where they all
equal each other is at X is equal to 1
if this is if this right here is f of X
G of X is going to look something like
this there's going to look something
like this and H of X is going to look
something like this H of X might look
something
like that and so they all they all
finally equal each other the only place
they equal each other is that a which is
the maximum of F so that also has to be
the maximum of G and H because that's
the most that's they can both get to
that value and they can't get to any
value higher than that that's an upper
bound on them
so this is also equal to B remember B is
just the maximum of G and it's also
equal to C which is the maximum of H so
a B and C are all equal to each other or
we can say choice choice D